gbagbo bravo non ouais je crois oui et
comme une arête patron du bar le 26
novembre
vous faites la voie d'un nouveau dessin
animé produit par pixar pour l'épauler
studios disney s'appelle le monde de
nemo vous faites là la voix de marine le
père de nemo marin voilà c'est le rôle
d'un poisson clown ça vous va très bien
mais en fait ça très très bien oui ses
impressions clown qui fait pas beaucoup
rire ils n'y arrivent pas bien ils
essayent milliards et qui est bien et
ouais c'est une belle aventure
c'est l'histoire d'un petit poisson
clown qui s'en va et puis finalement se
fait attraper par par un plongeur et qui
finit sa vie dans un aquarium et son
papa va le sauver
voilà et vous faites un film frank
dubosc avec marie-anne chazel oui qu'est
quoi elle réalise un film qui s'appelle
au secours j'ai 30 ans marie-anne chazel
oui marie-anne chazel et avec pierre
palmade sur adam et des autres journaux
et puis françois morel et puis plein
d'autres je joue pas le rôle d'un homme
de 30 ans mais d'un homme de 25 ans je
me sylvie plaît non mais voilà ça c'est
une comédie et est ce que est ce que
christian clavier passe sur le plateau
de temps en temps normal christian
clavier il produit le film effectivement
me tourne en ce moment lankais de corse
en corse avec jean reno et donc il
passera à la fin mai pour la fin donc on
a tous reçu un petit mot en revanche
très gentil de crise de la dette
vous avez vu son film faisait ritalin
dernier non à ces dommages sur le large
du boulot là non mercredi matin c'est
pas sûr qu'ils soient verts angola les
romains on va faire nos versions on va
faire l'autre versant est votre version
verra lequel on regarde nos gardes
alors vous êtes ce que vous avez eu la
visite de christian clavier sur le sur
le tournage ou écrit si on revient
régulièrement sur le plateau
il est très impliqué mais il arrive le
matin très tôt et puis on discute un
petit peu des scènes encore un peu il
sort le soir souvent on va dîner
ensemble pour un petit peu parlé de la
journée tout le monde pense qu'il est en
corse avec jean reno en train de le
nommer il fait des allers retours comme
ça et puis c'est quand il simple oubli
grit a par exemple j'ai vachement bien
l'algérie talent
oui oui le film c'est toute la nuit
comme une fois toi mais je les ai vus
j'ai vu que deux fois parce que je suis
partie sur un jeu les vues j'ai 18,2 3,3
fois j'ai vu trois fois puisque la
troisième fois dans la troisième fois
que l'acompte pas parce que c'était
connaissez les dialogues parce que
j'avais un jour n'a joué de vous il a
été vu dans l'avion déjà que j'ai peur
en avion mais non vous choisirez quelle
version bas je pense qu'on va mettre là
les deux peut-être comme ça christian
clavier pourra choisir ce moment je suis
en train de tourner mais aussi un film
met en scène quasiment
ensemble nos jours n'a même pas
empruntés jours sans même temps de jet
set
ah oui un attaché de presse homosexuels
non tu fais ça
mais sa part complètement corps non mais
c'est pas mal de temps dans gi mix ah
oui je veux bien nous le faire prendre
vraiment merdé l on pourra envoyer la
suivre et à l'éditeur
je peux toucher alors à 17 ans est une
drogue
est ce que tu peux nous parler de cette
période un peu trouble ou ta vie tu as
d'autres questions c'est mentir et vu la
question c'est quand est ce que vous
faites un film tous les deux une
question assez telle émission un peu
plus car yens alors là on est en train
de s'en occuper justement on est en
train de décrire autour des petites
annonces des personnages des petites
annonces object heureux
en fait deux
10h20